the potential of a big red wave in the
2022 midterm elections
if the party does not find its way and
reset its message after all that defund
the police nonsense that was
you know made made so public by the
squad
house democrats campaign chief warning
behind closed doors that if the midterms
were held today
republicans would win the majority in
congress
one democrat who attended the meeting
told politico quote
the polling looked pretty dismal to me
what are you thinking what do you think
you heard
well we are still a very long way away
from
2022 so do you think like jesse does
don't jinx it
yes just jesse does not want to jinx it
but i will say that in 2020
republicans came a lot closer to winning
the house than everybody thought that
they would
or most people anyway so there's a very
slim majority
uh with democrats i think what the
slimmest majorities in in decades in the
house for nancy pelosi
and regardless of that they've tried to
push through a lot of really far
left-wing ideas and also in the senate
being 50-50 they've taken advantage of
that now
when it comes to what the issues are
inflation obviously is a big one crime
is up when you have 42 percent
of people saying that they don't think
that that democrats can't be trusted on
the economy that's a big problem for
democrats given these factors
and when it when you're talking about
what people's livelihoods and crime
and democrats not being trusted with
that at all and defending the police and
having to kind of crawl back from
going in on the deep end with activists
who are totally on board but defending
the police
that's gonna be a hard message for them
to to get over so yeah they gotta work
on it there are also you know within the
democratic party even because they're so
liberal and everything else people
have a false impression i think within
for instance in the hispanic
community and as in the african-american
community
there's a lot bless you there's a lot of
conservatism
conservative conservatism whatever it is
a lot of conservative people within
these liberal groups
one issue which is pretty local is about
israel and uh you know support for
israel the squad
uh because i in in many ways i agree
with them about the palestinians being
even-handed and so forth
but the jewish community is very very
suspicious like in
cleveland we just had an election for
the ages i think it broke all the
records in terms of the money
that was spent on the election chantal
brown the joe biden
democrat against nina turner the
surrogate for bernie sanders
so there was this clash but nina turner
had in the past said things about israel
uh that they called into question her
loyalty to israel chantel brown went to
israel a couple years ago
and supported the jewish state you know
with the great emphasis
anyway yesterday was the election the uh
tuesday was the election
uh longest question ever
the the the turnout was very low 13
or so the jewish turnout was more than
double
that don't these issues count and
don't the democrats have to remember who
their constituents are
they do geraldo do you remember the
question no
joe biden has a messaging problem and a
management problem the message
was during the campaign we have to
defeat the virus
and then the economy will recover we
have defeated the virus and the economy
is recovering
but joe biden's acting like none of
those things are true
he's acting like we haven't beaten the
virus he's hyping up delta
we're back and forth on masks and oh i
don't know are we going to open the
schools geraldo
and then on the economy if the economy's
so great like he's bragging about
then why are we giving more free rent to
people
or why are we spending trillions more in
stimulus that's very popular
and all of the so-called wage gains that
are happening are offset
by high gas prices and inflation but the
management also is terrible
on the border and in inner cities
democrats control both and we have a
border crisis and a crime wave
and black americans don't like that
hispanic americans don't
like that suburban women don't like that
white males
that's unpopular across the board and
when you throw
critical race theory into that mix that
is an uphill climb
dana just jesse didn't answer my
question
[Music]
what about the importance of remembering
your constituencies
and isn't the fear of the squad's
radicalism and lack of loyalty
to groups like the jewish americans
isn't that
sure i'll just concede that it's an
important point if i and then i'll make
another one
and i think that the democrats really do
benefit from having uh congressman
sean patrick maloney as the head of
their uh congressional arm for this
cycle because he's at least willing to
tell them the hard truth
and he did the polling he put it out
there they leaked it out and said like
everybody on notice
that this nonsense could cost us the
majority and he wanted everybody to know
that on top of that
president biden's numbers have gone down
in the quinnipiac poll that just came
out today
in may he was at 49 approval today
august 4th he's at
46 percent it's about where president uh
trump was
so he's lost quite a bit of ground on
that front and so
the president who is in power in his
first midterm
in the first term usually loses seats
the republicans have three other things
going for them redistricting
that's probably going to give them five
to six seats uh recruiting
excellent recruiting and kevin mccarthy
puts a lot of emphasis on that
and fundraising nobody's going to be
short of money my last point is this the
republicans now have yet another issue
because what the bride administration
did yesterday to landlords all across
the country
that own 23 million rental housing units
all across the country
just found out that they were going to
get screwed again
so and they can't get the help that the
federal government gave out because the
states don't know how to get it to them
so there's an opportunity there if the
republicans can figure out a way
to message to them and to get to them
they might be able to get those votes
too
republicans you know still influenced in
a very profound way by president trump
in the
southern part of ohio a guy named mike
harry who was a lobbyist uh greg for the
coal industry was one of many candidates
i can't even remember
trump did 11 trump went down there did a
rally and the guy
that trump anointed won so he still has
some potency
yeah there you go i predicted that
yesterday on the show for those of you
who didn't watch you'll never be able to
prove that
party out of power always comes on
strong right there's always red waves
and blue waves what not but the red wave
is based on the crime wave
it's based on the wave of crt and other
denigrating
education trends and the wave of class
warfare that we're seeing as well
with with this landlord stuff and the
border bending wave too the spending
wave
there's a lot of waves the red wave can
only happen though if americans pull
themselves out of this deep rabbit hole
called the smartphone because i really
do believe the excesses of the left
uh took hold because we were ambivalent
and distracted
by so many things that everything that
we
hate and we should hate in hardcore left
politics
has it been able to sneak in right under
our noses because we
our nose was too busy in this but you
got to show up if you don't show up
then there's no wave there's there's no
wave
little little wave it goodbye wave it
goodbye
the fastest is hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else